we're in Chicago where Alan pan has
harnessed the wintertime elements to
create an eyesore he uses ice to slice
nice I saw it as cool because this guy
is clearly happily living out a nerd
fantasy winter is coming
the for Alan that's not a problem we
went to meet this internet inventor and
all-around ice ninja to ask why make
this frozen weapon making an ice sword
has been a childhood dream of mine I
really want something that looked like
something you'd expect out of a fantasy
sci-fi sort of a thing it's sort of a
ridiculous kind of fantasy weapon and it
does make you feel like you can you can
take out some like ice ochres or
something
how did Alan make a sword out of
something as fragile as ice a sword made
purely out of ice would be pretty
impractical because ice has a very
regular ordered crystal structure and
this means that it's really inflexible
and can't absorb impacts in fact because
of this incredibly ordered crystal
structure a small crack in the ice will
spread through it very quickly and it
will fracture
instead of making a sword out of ice
Alan is instead use something called
pykrete pykrete is just water with a
fibrous material frozen into it
Alan's pykrete is made of 80% water 14%
toilet paper and 6% sawdust these
materials disrupt the regular crystal
structure of ice allowing it to distort
rather than crack this means if a crack
does form rather than passing through
the entire ice sword it will soon meet a
layer of sawdust or toilet paper which
will stop the crack from spreading any
further
but just how strong is pykrete we set
Allen a concrete challenge three two one
hey I think this really really shows you
the power of pykrete I mean this is this
is what buildings are made out of and
this is ice and toilet paper I was
really surprised by the power of pykrete
just how much it was able to do and to
take it was really powerful stuff hey
George Allen dude you are cold it's
messed up man that snowman looked so
friendly